police in the canadian city of windsor
begin clearing out demonstrators the
protesters have blocked a vital bridge
crossing the border with the u.s for
days you're holding a gun for no reason
most are truck drivers who've led the
protest against a government order
requiring they be vaccinated against
covet 19 to cross over
many drove off voluntarily
[Applause]
but others stayed on the street near the
ambassador bridge a small yet defiant
crowd of people who say they will not
give in
and the mandates and the passports and
let us live our lives we're sick and
tired of it about 25 percent of trade
between the u.s and canada passes over
the ambassador bridge auto manufacturers
are especially reliant on the route and
say they've been losing tens of millions
of dollars during the protests
but many of those drivers transporting
goods say they've had enough
on friday i can work and on monday i
can't it's ridiculous
i survive this long i'm a big boy i look
after myself i don't need the government
to tell me what kind of medicine i need
to take
the trucker's protest has resonated in
other parts of canada leading to
criticism of prime minister justin
trudeau
in the capital ottawa thousands of
people gathered outside parliament hill
on saturday to protest against
government mandates and in toronto
demonstrators marched on the streets
showing support for the so-called
freedom convoy
that name has also been taken up in
france where protesters drove hundreds
of vehicles into paris and a similar
rally against covet restrictions
but these protests have angered others
in canada
what does freedom mean what freedom do
they want in january and february all
the provincial governments and the
federal government started to say that
they will unlock things they will open
up things this was already in the works
what they've done is actually shut it
down
the protests are now impacting more than
trade and have extended beyond covet 19
into a call for an end to perceived
restrictions on personal freedoms
katya lopissa yan al jazeera